[Musique]
notre invité qui est Jean-Paul Palomeros
bonjour merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
ancien chef d'état-major de l'armée de
l'air ancien commandant suprême allié de
la transformation de l'OTAN alors on va
peut-être regarder d'abord ces images je
vais vous les décrire les dernières
qu'on ait reçu de la région de de Barth
mouth on y voit un l'ampleur est
l'intensité des combats qui sont
actuellement menés les combats les plus
acharnés les plus violents depuis le
début de la guerre de la veuve même de
la ministre de la Défense
ukrainienne la plupart des civils ont
fui évidemment la région et l'on
comprend pourquoi quand on aperçoit ces
images il y a encore malgré tout des
évacuations de civils vous apercevez ici
un véhicule blindé censé évacuer ou au
moins tenter d'évacuer les derniers
civils retranchés dans des dans des
bâtiments un mot de ce qui se passe
là-bas aujourd'hui Jean-Paul Palomeros
pourquoi cette ville de dix mille
habitants seulement est-elle devenue
l'un des un jeu clé de ce conflit
il y a une sorte de fixation qui s'est
faite c'est auto alimenté avec
toute cette dimension il y a une
dimension qui est très très politique
très très géo stratégique c'est voilà
les Ukrainiens ne veulent pas lâcher une
once un mètre carré de leur terrain et
donner l'impression que que les Russes
peuvent reprendre l'avantage et
réoccuper cette région annexée là on est
dans le blast de données donc là il y a
un enjeu très très politique je dirais
et puis après il y a des enjeux
militaires qui sont un peu moins
évidents l'aspect stratégique si vous
voulez de baroute évidemment ça serait
un autre verrou vert une progression
russe potentielle vers cramator ce qui
est donc cette
comment dirait cette poussée qu'on avait
vu dans les premiers temps de la guerre
où les Russes avaient vraiment poussé
vers l'Est bon maintenant tout la
question savoir si les Russes ont
vraiment cette aptitude cette
possibilité de pousser donc c'est vrai
que darkmouth sur les dard sont devenus
des symboles alors il y a aussi
effectivement l'implication de Wagner
qui est un élément supplémentaire
et Wagner prise aussi une qui veut
absolument démontrer à la fois que
Wagner est une force armée
à part entière qu'elle obtient des
succès là où l'armée russe stagne c'est
à la fois son ego et et ça ça volonté de
d'apporter quelque part ça contribution
à cette guerre et de valoriser son
groupe Wagner alors je rappelle que
Wagner a été conçu comme une société de
mercenaire illégale en Russie à
l'origine l'objectif au départ était de
créer des zones d'influence procrément
essentiellement en Afrique le Mali la
Centrafrique on en a beaucoup parlé sans
intervention officielle russe on voit
bien avec le conflit ukrainien les
lignes ont quand même bougé ces derniers
mois
elles sont complètement oui elles ont
bougé et il y a une confusion totale qui
d'ailleurs est un des éléments à prendre
en compte dans les difficultés qu'on
rencontre l'armée russe et dans et donc
dans le changement de commandement le N
plus une ième changement de commandement
qui est qui a eu lieu donc hier
on sent bien que cette lutte il y a une
lutte de pouvoir quelque part une lutte
de pouvoir militaire qui pardon je vous
interrompre mais on a vu le Kremlin
quand même contre dire ça mini c'est
l'armée de l'ombre de valadimir Poutine
le Kremlin il y en a pas hésité à aller
contredire lorsqu'ils annonçaient la
prise de Solidar il y a de l'eau dans le
gaz aujourd'hui
je sais pas c'est une expression tout à
fait adaptée effectivement
je sais pas il est clair que Monsieur
joue sa carte il joue sa carte jusqu'à
quel point elle peut la jouer comme ça
de manière indépendante donc on voit
qu'il y a une sorte de rééquilibrage
permanent je pense qu'il y a du tirage
comme vous dites entre les forces armées
régulières entre général simov et
Monsieur priusine vraisemblablement il
peut difficilement d'être autrement le
problème pour Wagner c'est quoi on
entend dire que
cette milice qui était donc l'armée de
l'ombre de Vladimir Poutine et qui se
retrouve finalement en première ligne a
envie d'être reconnu pour ses actions
envie d'avoir le champ libre peut-être
aussi
oui alors derrière tout ça il y a quand
même des intérêts partout Wagner a été
engagé
c'était pour au départ soit disant
apporter une aide à soutien par exemple
c'est le cas au Mali aux forces en place
au gouvernement à l'âgeinette en place
mais c'est au bout du compte c'est quand
même pour tirer profit des ressources
essentiellement des ressources
naturelles des différents pays ça peut
être de l'or dans un pays ça peut être
des ressources pétrolières gazières de
toute nature plutôt médiéro donc c'est
quand même ça c'est quand même le sens
du profit qui domine et deuxième élément
c'est qu'évidemment Wagner échappe à
tout contrôle
d'une force armée et ne respecte
évidemment aucune des règles de la
guerre on a vu qu'il y avait des
prisonniers qui avaient été envoyés sur
le front il y a besoin de beaucoup
d'hommes ça c'est sûr que c'est une
question qu'on se pose ce groupe à
l'origine fort d'environ 10
mercenaires aurait beaucoup recruté
notamment des prisonniers on parle de
40000 recrutements il sera à peu près 50
000 aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est
possible déjà d'avancer un chiffre ça
reste très opaque
bah oui les lignes sont quand même un
peu floues
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'au départ en
tout cas un groupe tel que Wagner qui a
des moyens financiers peut se permettre
de payer ces mercenaires alors que je
pense que les recrues russes
n'ont pas la même n'ont pas les mêmes
faveurs c'est même évident donc il y a
cet aspect là maintenant si Wagner
continue à gonfler il a quand même un
problème de ressources c'est un peu
l'extrême limite d'aller chercher des
prisonniers comme on l'a vu en prison de
leur promettre d'ailleurs en dépit de
tout acte de justice de les libérer s'il
faut bien leur travail enfin c'est tout
ça est en train d'entrer entraîner une
grande confusion qui ne peut qu'ajouter
aux malheurs si vous voulez des uns et
des autres puisque à partir du moment il
y a plus de règles il y a plus de code
de conduite on est dans les excès comme
on l'a vu d'ailleurs pratiquement depuis
le début de ce conflit
restez avec nous Jean-Paul palomero on
va prendre la direction à faire une
parenthèse par le terrain retrouver
notre correspondant à Kiev Gulliver crag
pour prendre justement le coup du front
prendre des nouvelles du terrain à
soléda Gulliver krach bonjour Dans les
dernières déclarations des Ukrainiens ce
matin on assurait tenir les positions
sur ce front de Solidar même si on admet
aujourd'hui et on le comprend quand on
voit ces images une situation
extrêmement difficile
oui absolument le ministre de la Défense
les ministères de la Défense Paris
excusez-moi a fait son briefing mensuel
ce matin un briefing un peu plus étendu
évidemment et ils se sont exprimés à
différents représentants du ministère en
fait sur la situation à Solidar mais
aucune annonce vraiment à faire si ce
n'est ce que de dire que cela n'a pas
vraiment de sens que d'exprimer en
termes de pourcentage de terrain dans la
ville de soledar qui serait contre les
par les Ukrainiens ou par les Russes
puisque des bâtiments des rues des
angles de rue changent demain
constamment la situation est extrêmement
violente les Russes sont dans la ville
de soleda mais ne contrôle pas la ville
on ne peut pas dire en ce moment que les
Russes contrôlent la ville les
Ukrainiens affirment défendre mes
admettent effectivement que il est très
difficile ils disent infligés des pertes
très importantes sur les Russes c'est
absolument incroyable aussi parce qu'on
a vu des vidéos tournées des drones
Ukrainiens on voit bien la tactique
employée par ces mercenaires de Wagner
qui sont envoyés parfois très légèrement
armés vers les positions ukrainiennes
dans la ville et aux alentours de la
ville de soleda mais je pense qu'il est
clair que les Ukrainiens subissent et
très importantes aussi voilà d'où ces
appels réitérés aussi
parquet à recevoir un soutien
logistique on sait que volodime Zelinski
attendait des armes supplémentaires la
France a déjà fait des des promesses on
parle beaucoup aussi des fameux léopards
allemands qui qui sont sur le point
d'arriver
entretenu hier à le vivre dans l'ouest
de l'Ukraine avec son homologue polonais
Angel Douda qui a promis que la Pologne
enverrait je pense une quinzaine de cet
ongles par mais seulement dans le cadre
d'une coalition internationale il faut
que la Pologne obtienne Laval de
l'Allemagne pour envoyer ces temps
allemand l'Allemagne de la voix du
chancelet olafchaulz se dit ne pas avoir
reçu de demande pour le moment mais
l'impression qu'on a c'est que la
Pologne et d'autres pays aussi veulent
mettre la pression sur des pays un peu
plus réticents comme l'Allemagne de
fournir justement ces temps que à
l'Ukraine c'est un peu la France qui a
selon Paulo dinosaelenski en tout cas
ouvert la voie on annonçant c'était
juste à la fin de l'année dernière je
pense l'envoi de ces véhicules de
reconnaissance qui peuvent être
classifiés comme des tanks techniquement
c'est des tanks mais c'est des temps que
léger pas des temps que d'assaut pas des
chars d'assaut l'Ukraine réclame de car
comme c'est léopard par exemple merci
beaucoup Gulliver crack en direct de
Kiev pour pour France 24 je me tourne le
nouveau vers vous Jean-Paul Palomeros on
a entendu ces appels en réitérer aux
Occidentaux de livrer des armes du
matériel efficace pour faire face
notamment face à cette force Wagner qui
est je le rappelle accusé de nombreuses
exactions ça pourrait vraiment changer
la donne ça fait bientôt ça fera bientôt
un an qu'on commente ce conflit cette
guerre qui sévit en Ukraine on a le
sentiment d'en être toujours au même
point finalement aujourd'hui
oh non il s'est passé beaucoup de choses
non non on est certainement pas au même
point les les forces sont présents
maintenant sont se connaissent bien
elles savent où elles en sont en
stratégie qu'au début on avait un flou
stratégique du côté des Russes qui leur
a coûté d'ailleurs très cher
maintenant il y a une véritable
opposition la ligne on voit la ligne de
France on voit les axes principaux Nord
et Sud c'est assez clair on voit bien
que les Russes sont en train de faire
parler d'essaye essaie de faire parler
la quantité non c'est vrai en termes de
ressources humaines ils ont sans doute
des difficultés quand même alimenter
leur machine de guerre c'est un vrai
sujet de l'autre côté les Alliés bon
soutiennent l'Ukraine mais il faut quand
même souligner que c'est tout ce qu'on
fournit à l'Ukraine doit correspondre à
une stratégie si vous voulez et les
Ukrainiens
il semble-t-il sont encore dans cette
interrogation ils doivent évidemment
défendre le front ça on en a parlé avec
barmouth ils doivent aussi continuer à
être dans l'initiative si vous voulez
pour pouvoir reprendre du terrain ça
c'est leur volonté que ce soit au sud
c'est peut-être prioritaire ou au nord
mais il leur faut pour ça effectivement
les moyens adaptés et c'est là que la
discussion rentre en ligne de contact
avec les alliés deux points sur ce sujet
d'abord effectivement ce cas fournit la
France a une exercé ce que fournissent
initialement les Allemands les
maraudeurs voire les Britanniques ce
sont quand même des moyens dans les
Allemands les Américains pardon ce sont
des moyens qu'on peut considérer comme
léger qui sont extrêmement utiles et
assez mobiles la question des chars
lourds n'est visiblement pas tranché
et
pourtant il faut que les Alliés si je
les appelle comme ça décident oui ou non
veulent-ils apporter cette force de
manœuvre essentielle que sont les
charlourdes dans cette bataille et
rapidement parce que il suffit pas
d'annoncer qu'on va envoyer X et
quelques dizaines de
d'éléments comme ça il faut ensuite
construire d'abord former les Ukrainiens
sur ces différents matériels c'est
compliqué
d'un autre côté organisé tout ce qui est
maintenant ce soutien évidemment les
munitions qui sont d'ailleurs de nature
diverses ça ça complexifie encore la
tâche donc il faut plusieurs semaines au
bas mot pour faire tout ça si les
occidentaux le voulez vraiment et se
décider aujourd'hui il pourrait aider
l'Ukraine à s'imposer à l'emporter face
à la Russie
oui sans doute mais il faudrait qu'ils y
mettent vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
moyens enfin encore plus que ce qu'ils
font aujourd'hui beaucoup plus et ça
c'est la question des semaines à venir
maintenant le les alliés sont confrontés
à cette question vont-ils jusqu'au bout
les Ukrainiens ont demandé aussi vous
l'avez entendu des missiles à longue
portée ça c'est une question qui est
loin d'être réglée également donc
finalement ça met bien les alliés dont
le responsabilité par rapport à une
volonté politique et stratégique
ukrainienne qui est très claire et à une
opposition russe qui qui fait jouer
comme je le disais tout à l'heure là le
nombre la quantité comme ça souvent
était le cas d'ailleurs dans les dans
les dans les guerres menées par la
Russie
à l'heure où la Russie est en train de
communiquer via son ministère de la
Défense et évoque un succès dans son
offensif sur le front de donies Merci à
VOUS Jean-Paul palamoros merci